Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
and ahhh.
ahhh,
just checking in on you.
Just check in and I,
the voice is coming back.
I've been real good.
Been drinking the throat coat tea and having the lodge [inaudible]
um,
I had a great week.
I did the uh,
the,
I thought it was a two year anniversary sit three year anniversary of the
goddamn comedy jam.
And a I sang for the first time,
came out dressed as a Johnny paycheck and I saying that take this job and shove
it my working here no more.
Um,
and then I sat in a play drums afterwards,
played sweet child of mine for the uh,
the finale.
And uh,
you know what's funny about that song?
I never really listened to the drums once slash started playing the guitar Solo.
That's one of those guitars,
solo songs.
I always have to fucking real.
I can't listen to it one time through.
I always have to rewind it back.
You know,
we really starts slash really starts getting going.
I fucking loved that Solo and I was so listening to what he was doing.
I never really listened to all the cool drums underneath it.
Um,
the Great Steven Adler,
so I had a great time doing all of that shit last night.
I did a fucking benefit for the troops there and,
uh,
I just had a,
it was a fucking amazing night.
Just,
uh,
went out there.
One of those nights you walk on stage like,
you know what?
I don't feel like doing my act.
And you just start fucking talking and it works rather than you're bombing,
you know,
the nights when you don't feel like doing your act and you don't do your act and
you start bombing,
then you reluctantly go into your act.
It becomes a,
you know,
they get all grumpy.
The crowd sitting there like,
what the fuck is this guy's problem came down here to laugh at.
He's a,
he's,
he's coming out,
he's being all fresh.
Um,
oh,
it's just one of those,
just one of those great nights.
And other than that,
I've just been stuck in a writer's room,
so I have no idea what the fuck is going on in the world.
This is what this is.
This is what happens when they go into the writer's room.
I have no fucking idea what goes on in the world where I'm working on episodes
one and two.
We have our first table read tomorrow so well,
uh,
I get a fucking,
I get a look at my lines,
make sure if I sell the joke so they get laughs so we don't have to fucking
write new jokes.
That's how it works.
Uh,
the madness has begun again.
So,
um,
I can't remember what the fuck I talked about cause I already started this
podcast that I mentioned that my wife came into work today with my lovely
daughter and everybody got to see her and it was the highlight of my day and try
to make sure she does that more often.
You know,
they're only little one time I came home early and I come home a little early
now.
Right.
I got the whole excuse talk cause I gotta go home and see my baby,
right.
So I come home and she's got this little chair,
you know,
that just like fucking clamps onto the table and uh,
she sits at that thing and she just sat there talking to me like,
how,
you know,
trying to talk to me is,
I had dinner in my,
a lovely wife was downstairs sleeping.
We just basically had our first dinner date with,
so it was so cool.
It wasn't me.
It amazes me.
Is she like cracks herself up.
She can't speak a word of any language.
And so,
but she sits there and she thinks about stuff and she just kinda chuckled,
sit there going,
I'm just,
she just be by herself and I'm just,
it kills me.
I'm like,
what is she thinking about?
Like to make yourself laugh,
do you got to think about something that's fucked up?
Which means you got to have a knowledge of something that's like,
you know how things should be like that when somebody comes walking in the room,
they're just supposed to walk into the room.
They're not supposed to bump ahead of fall on their ass.
Like,
you know what's normal?
I kind of share like what's our idea?
Normal.
I Dunno.
This is like one of these things that,
you know,
when you watch like the uh,
one of those animal programs and they start telling you what the fucking ant,
what the animal's thinking.
You just,
you just want to be like,
how about God's name?
Would you know that?
You know,
when the shark does this,
it's actually a,
it's actually afraid because it's blah,
blah,
blah.
They,
they do this when they,
when they fucking make this noise with their mouth and it's actually a,
this is like a mating call and say,
how did you figure that out?
How did you figure that out?
Like you followed this thing around the fucking woods.
It made that noise and then another bird showed up and they started fucking,
these are like birds.
Like,
how did you figure that out?
How do you keep,
do you ever try to keep up with a bird?
I've never tried that.
That's gotta be hard as hell.
How many fucking people are in the woods.
Yeah.
Fucking bird gets like performance anxiety.
You know,
you think you can keep fucking,
if you looked out the window and there was like 10 birds with cameras looking at
you.
Okay,
right and shit down and everything.
You'd be like,
what the fuck's with these birds?
Then you kind of forget what you were doing.
I've never understood how they do that.
Like how big the jungle is,
all of that shit.
You had the cameras set up and you were able to capture this fucking thing
killing this other animal.
Well like they're following like a fucking unbelievably deadly snake.
They're following it through the forest
and then they'll fucking be on the other side of the log and it's,
it's coming over the top.
It's like is that,
is that fucking snake in the union?
It looked like it went back to one.
When you reset and action.
It's like it comes like comes over the bucket thing.
I swear to God,
I watched one one time,
I'm telling you,
they set this fucking mouse up the one day they had footage of the mouse.
It's in the fucking woods,
or I guess if it's a poisonous snake,
it's gotta be the jungle right at that point,
I don't know the forest,
all right.
In this fucking mouse is like freaking out in this snake.
A rattlesnake is on like it's,
you know,
it's on its path.
It's chasing this thing.
So the fucking thing goes down this hole,
this mouse.
Okay.
And then they showed the snake,
you know,
coming over the log and then it goes down the same fucking hole and then all of
a sudden I'm in the hall with the mouse.
Like there was a camera down that whole like,
how the fuck,
how to fuck did,
did you know to put the camera down there?
Right.
And then the mouse is down.
Then you'd see the thing freaking out.
Like,
you know,
like some fucking set up man,
right in the fucking snakes coming down.
It's like Joe Pesci when he thinks he's getting made,
he walks it.
Ah,
no,
Bam.
That was it.
The snake came in and fucking killed the mouse.
And I remember just feeling,
I just was sitting there watching it going like,
did I just watch your fucking murder?
Did that thing that was like a hit.
That wasn't just some random shit that they kind of caught like,
you know,
when they see like Cheetahs chasing down some fucking thing.
I Dunno.
I think they ought to investigate that one.
That was clearly a,
uh,
it was something about it that's definitely worthy of,
of an investigation.
A suspicious,
you know,
you know when somebody dies and they just say he'd say,
yeah,
seem like natural causes.
What's that other word they use?
I don't fucking know.
I uh,
I always root for Anil whatever,
animals dying and there's a lot of animals that I don't like cause they're
fucking scary.
You know,
when you watch like,
uh,
one of those big cats,
which I love those fucking things.
When you watch them,
you know,
when you watch them taken down one of those bulls,
it's like I'm all for the fucking bull.
Like rooting the thing on.
Then all of a sudden it kicks one of the lines in the face or it stabs him with
the horn and then the lion limps off.
Then I feel bad for the line.
Like I fuck man,
I had the lines going to die.
Now you know,
I don't like how Eunice and I fucking hate monkeys.
I like gorillas.
I don't like monkeys.
I definitely don't like chimpanzees and I'm definitely going to go see planet of
the apes and I'm rooting for the humans,
sponges.
I know that,
you know,
if we win,
we're going to continue to cause global warming and throw TV sets into the
ocean.
I just a,
I don't like those fucking ticks.
Like that first planet of the apes,
this latest reboot of it.
When the things walking down the street and had like pants on and the guys like
Holden,
it's fucking hand.
Yeah,
like the,
and I always go to the planet of the apes movies and we just exchange looks the
entire fucking time just looking at each other like,
this is just fucking,
this is so fucking weird.
They're so fucking weird.
They're so close to what we are,
you know,
but they can like rip your face off and they just don't give a shit.
I'm actually wondering to them [inaudible] I dunno,
I don't like fucking monkeys.
I respect him and uh,
but I could never live in,
in a,
in a country where they're just out in the wild
like that,
like party at DNC,
like those things like in India or some shit and some guy will be walking down
the street and this fucking random monkey will just run up behind him and give
him like a,
the monkey version of a fucking flying drop kick and the guy does like a face
plant and the monkey takes off like laughing at him.
Like,
um,
I,
I wouldn't be able to handle that.
I'd be like,
I'm gonna fucking kill that thing.
Not Kill it,
kill it.
Because then I feel bad,
but I'm going to throw a fucking rock at it
right
from walking down some fucking godforsaken road in a monkey knocks me over and
then the happy goes up the fucking train.
It's jumping up and down,
all proud of itself.
I would,
I would love to think that,
you know,
for all the Peta people listening that I would be mature enough to not do
something,
but uh,
I would have to do something
if I lived in a country that had fucking just monkeys running around.
I would have,
like,
I would,
you know what I would do,
I would design like a portable firehose,
right?
You know,
at that level of fucking velocity and after they fucking did whatever they did,
throw their poo at me or whatever the fuck they did,
I would just blast them right out of the trees.
You know,
those little ones
there was fucking chimpanzees.
You can't have him.
Can't have it.
It's amazing how we just found out now that chimpanzees can like rip your face
off.
You know,
like when they go to kill another chimpanzee,
they like to rip their balls right off,
twist their foot off and fucking rip their faith.
They do all this fucking crazy shit.
Then they get all amped up afterwards.
All the other apes after they fucking killed that one,
that jumping around all talking shit about what the fuck they just did.
Um,
there's no fucking way,
there's no fucking way I can live in a country that had that type of shit.
I went,
I would be fucking pack in the entire time.
You know,
like if my neighbor ever just like for the years,
like in Hollywood,
like the chimpanzee was,
was so fucking castable.
And now that I've actually gotten to a writer's room and I talked to these guys
about different shoots,
everybody has a monkey story.
Everybody has a fucking monkey where it's like,
ah,
man,
you know,
can't do it,
man.
Can't do it.
I won't work with them.
And I'm like,
really?
And they got why?
What happens is the guy,
you know what?
This is what the fuck happens.
Okay,
you took,
you know,
you've got a finite amount of time.
The monkey's going to do kind of what you want it to do.
And then it's going to get to a fucking point where the monkeys just going to go
fucking ape shit,
no pun intended.
And it's just going to do what?
It's going to start flying around the fucking set and it's something somebody is
going to get jumped.
Okay.
You know,
I worked with a guy,
he got fucking attacked by a monkey on a set.
There's no fucking way.
There is no fucking way.
I'm of a long time ago we did the uh,
when I did the opie and Anthony Show,
right.
Which I'm hoping,
you know now that opie schedules all freed up now.
I'm hoping that may be,
you know,
guns and roses can get back together.
Huh.
Who knows,
stranger things have happened.
Um,
yeah,
I was on the opiate Anthony show and somebody brought in,
it was,
uh,
I think it was a,
a baby tiger and the thing was fucking adorable,
but I'll tell you right now,
it was like the size,
it was between a house cat in a bobcat.
As far as the size it was no,
I mean it was kind of like the size of a house cat.
But it was fucking jacked.
You know,
it's was,
we'd like a baby bear because it's going to turn into this three,
four,
five,
600 pound fucking thing.
When it's a baby,
it's still like,
dude,
that thing could fuck me up there.
Freddy Kruger pause that,
those bears APP.
So they got this fucking,
uh,
they bring in this baby tiger.
It's the white one,
right?
The,
the bill burr version of the tiger and they bring it in.
I remember Anthony was going out and then he goes,
baby animals.
They're adorable.
Like he fucking loves him in the fucking thing was the goddamn tiger was not in
a good mood and it was at going,
wow.
Wow,
I'm doing like this baby.
Little fucking roaring.
Yeah.
So they'd go,
do you want to hold that thing?
And I was like,
no.
I mean,
yeah.
If you de and you fucking duct tape,
it's fucking cute little mouth shut.
Yeah.
I'd maybe done.
Yeah,
maybe then I would fuck with it.
You know?
Could you put some boxing gloves on and all four of its paws?
I,
yeah.
Then I would do it,
then I would do it.
But I,
I just,
you know,
I've gotten scratched by a house cat.
It fucking kills.
They'd hurts that thing with its baby lion paw.
The fucking thing was the size of like four house cats.
Like if you took all four house cats paws and you put it together,
that was the size of this fucking thing.
Yeah.
So Anthony fucking starts,
you know,
playing with the thing.
And I remember he ended up getting scratched to get scratched on his neck and
then they told me how to go get a fucking shot.
I don't know if he ever it and um,
yeah,
it's weird cause there's a white guy.
I should be the kind of guy that goes around fucking with animals.
But uh,
I don't,
I do,
but I don't,
I go to the zoo,
I kind of fuck with them,
but I don't know why.
I just want to see,
you know what it is.
I want to see them do what they do.
I don't want to see him chilling.
That's fucking boring to me.
I want to see him kind of flipping out.
You know,
like I hate when you finally go see a poisonous snake and it's just laying there
all wound up like some climbing rope,
you know,
I want it to be like on it,
like I'll fucking murder you.
I want to see it do some snake shit.
That's the thing that you go to the zoo.
It's like everybody,
it's like,
it's like everybody's a in a spa or some shit,
you know,
just chilling out.
Oh God.
How much a pdf people are going to hate me on this one.
Talking about shooting monkeys and comparing the zoo to his spot though,
just to let you know all the conditions.
I know,
I'm just saying that chill or depressed.
I don't know what they are,
but then they're not doing anything.
You just like,
yeah,
I get it.
I can't get out of here.
So,
you know what I mean?
It'd be like,
you know,
going to look at like human beings and they're all in jail.
Like,
why would you want to do that?
Some guy just fucking sitting there on a cot like,
yeah,
I'm here for the rest of my life.
Say All right,
nice talking to you.
Can you just move onto the next guy?
You don't want to see that,
right?
You want to go down a little food court.
You want to watch people,
people free like food court is like the Serengeti,
you know,
watering hole for human beings and you just go down.
Then you look at all the different species down there,
all interacting,
you know,
everybody seems to be getting along.
Then all of a sudden somebody comes when those little kids comes by with the
wheels on his sneakers and freaks everybody out,
the herd starts to stampede.
Sound like that.
At least that.
Maybe that's on black Friday.
I don't know what happens.
Um,
anyways,
I,
I got a bunch of reads I have to do because there was no reads during the 4th of
July weekend.
One,
two tree,
four,
five,
five reads,
but they're fund rates.
I always make it fun.
You know what I mean?
I'm the kind of guy that can make advertise and fun.
I like to think,
can we go,
oh,
look who's back.
It's all zip
brought up.
Are you hiring?
Why
do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
With Ziprecruiter,
you can post your job to 100 plus job sites with just one click.
Then their powerful technology efficiently matches the right people to your job
better than anyone else.
That's why Ziprecruiter is different,
unique.
Even unlike other job sites,
sip recruiter doesn't depend on candidates finding you.
It finds them.
In fact,
over 80% of jobs posted on ZipRecruiter.
Get a qualified candidate in just 24 hours.
You don't have time to be meeting every Tom,
Dick,
and fucking Harry coming into your office.
You need to work.
Just post your job,
put it up on the thing and let's zip recruiter to do the work.
No juggling emails or calls to your office.
Simply screen rate and manage candidates all in one place with Ziprecruiter's,
easy to use dashboard and right now my listeners can post jobs on ZipRecruiter
for free.
That's right free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/burr that's ziprecruiter.com one more time.
Try It for free.
Go to
ziprecruiter.com/burn a loot crate everybody,
give me a be the envy of all your friends and get 100% exclusive traits of loot
crate.com/burr and enter my code bird to save $3 off on any new subscription.
July's loot crate theme is monkeys just an animation.
Uh,
well,
have you got an f is for family fucking swag.
The Birch page,
he's up by the way.
He could buy some fuckingF is for family shit.
A copy points mentioned at least three times a spot.
Just right.
What the fuck you want me to say?
I don't know what that means.
Mentioned at least three times per spot
on a quest for epic gear,
housewares and collectibles.
Loot crate has it.
The best surprise,
you know,
is coming.
Luke crate offers an epic range of pop culture items for less than $20 a month.
If you're more of a fanatical Fashionista than try loop where monthly wearables
and accessibles with coke classics and your favorite franchises.
Do you guys have any idea what this is?
If you want to get fancy,
get a bigger box with even bigger loop with Luke Craig DX.
Want to geek out your pet.
Try loot pets.
Offer expires does expires July 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific.
I have no idea what this stuff is.
It's a bunch of t shirts and slippers and shit
with the animation on it.
I guess in July's loot crate you'll find items from the teenage mutant Ninja
Turtles.
Okay,
good.
Bob's burgers.
Loved that show.
Future Rama.
Love it.
Rick and Morty.
I got to watch that show.
Everybody's telling me it's great.
One lucky subscriber will also,
when a mega crate of mega creed of seriously epic proportions,
you have until the 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific to subscribe and receive that month's
crate and when the cut off happens,
that's it.
It's fucking,
oh,
go to Luke crate.com/burn and enter my code.
Berbee you are are to say $3 off on any new subscription today.
Oh,
here's one of our newer ones.
This is the Wednesday one right here,
right number three Humpday Fi fo club look at good,
doesn't need to cost a fortune five four club is revolutionizing the way men
look at.
Oh look,
they found a way to make a great look and mother fuck of close,
affordable.
Everyone.
Five folk club also understands that your time is extremely valuable.
Why wasted at the mall or wandering around in the stores each month.
They'll send you a curated box of two to three items that are handpicked to
match the current season and your style.
Five folk club partners with cutting edge designers and brands.
So you'll get the same quality at top designer clothes.
What?
So you'll get the same quality as top designer clothes for way less.
Okay,
sorry.
They've been helping men with fashion for over 15 years and shipped to over
100,000 men every month.
Chris Paul and Mark Walberg use five folk club and five pho is featured in Gq
vibe and in style among other publications.
All right.
So you know they got the cool clothes,
they know what they're doing.
So if you don't work,
if you don't know what you're doing,
that's okay because
we'll help you build your wardrobe one month at a time.
Because when you look good,
you feel good.
It's a fact of life.
You get $120 worth of clothes for just $60 a month.
You can pause or cancel anytime,
no commitments it.
And as a five,
four club member,
you'll also receive up to 50% off items in their online shopping and access to
exclusive members only items,
free shipping and size exchanges.
I gotta read this kind of white cause I'm afraid that they're going to bitch
being like you're making it sound like they only make clothes for bet black
people with your black sent while you do this.
All right,
go to five four club.com right now and enter Promo Code Burr and they'll give
you 50% off your first month's packages,
plus a free pair of sunglasses.
That's 50% off your first packages packets,
sorry.
At five folk club,
felt,
F,
Abbvie,
O,
u r club.com,
Promo Code Code Bar.
That's fivefold club.com promo coper.
They make clothes for blacks,
whites,
Asians,
Jews,
Mongolians,
and even North Koreans.
All right.
Oh,
here we go.
Is another one.
And don't cheat.
Um,
talk about wearing a suit.
Wearing a suit says about you.
Oh,
I'm wearing a suit.
That usually means I'm in trouble or I'm at an event I don't want to go to.
Indochino is making it easy to get a perfectly tailored suit at an incredible
price.
You can choose from hundreds of top quality fabrics and personalize your suit
just the way you want it,
whether it's for work,
a wedding,
or another special occasion.
Indochino as suited up hundreds of thousands of men and are now the largest made
to measure men's brand men's wear brand in the world.
Here's how it works.
Visit a showroom or shop online@indochino.com pick your fabric.
Choose your customizations from lapels to pleats to jacket linings in more.
Uh,
submit your measurements.
Place your order and wait for it to arrive.
And just a few weeks this week,
my listeners can get any premium Indochino suit for 379 dollars@indochino.com
that's like fucking biggie is the age old bio,
but a big,
you just lay down slow.
What song was that one fucking song?
Was He spelling out the I n.
You just order the shit bill.
You trying to wrap?
Yes.
You think you're doing a good job?
No.
All right.
I'll just read the copy here.
That's 50% off regular prices for made to measure premium suits plus shipping is
free.
That's indochino.com promo code birth for any premium suit for $379 and free
shipping.
Incredible deal for a suit that will fit you better than anything off the rack.
Ever could fuck this up.
I got to read one more.
Okay.
Let's get the fucking zone.
All right.
The Black Tux,
like the Ohio State University.
This is the black Tux.
These are the people to go for a black Tux.
All right.
There's only so many opportunities in life to wear a Tuxedo.
So when you're,
I just picture some of loony Illuminati event underneath a mountain underneath
the,
I wanted to shout it from a mountain.
Uh,
so when your big day or special event rolls in around this summer,
look,
just as great as you feel with suits from the black tux.com with high quality
rental suits and Tuxedos delivered to your doorstep.
The Black Tux gives you a new way to rent plus with their free home.
Try on you can one plus what they're free home.
Try on.
You can see the fit and feel the quality of your suit months before your event.
Who the fuck is that organized?
And the best part is it's completely done online.
The Black Tux dot coms lets you create your look or choose from tons of style
stylist.
Selected outfits suits like these usually cost retail for $1,200.
But at the the Black Tux,
they start at just 95 bucks,
$95 if you have any questions or issues,
their expert customer care team has your back every step of the way.
After ordering your suit will arrive 14 days before your event.
If anything is less than perfect,
the black Tux will send you a free replacement right away.
When your event is over,
just drop your rental back in the mail.
Shipping is free both ways.
How easy is that stand out at your event for the right reasons with the Black
Tux to get $20 off your purchase,
visit the black tux.com/ [inaudible] that's the black tux.com/burr for $20 off
your purchase.
Oh my God.
Mercifully it's fucking over.
Good Lord.
That was dealt with.
There was a lot.
That was a lot.
Hey,
guess what I'm talking about booking my 2018 I'm already working on that type of
shit and a,
I gotta tell you I was so impressed with the,
the,
the track in Austria at the Austrian Grand Prix.
I think I'm going to go to that race next year and I'm going to do a show and
fucking Austria.
What do you think about that?
And then the next fucking week is to British Grand Prix.
So God dammit,
what the fuck?
I might as well go to England,
right?
I'll knock out two.
I'm gonna knock out a couple of two,
three races a year,
you know,
until it starts getting shady and I got to start going to those fucking
countries where I'm like,
um,
these people hate us is this bad place I'll have to check out with like the
fucking Goddamn a on a United States embassy.
Yeah.
What did you guys do to these people?
And uh,
they over it yet like a,
as he was telling me,
as,
as her,
biogen is a beautiful place to go.
I don't know.
I see that a in that z and I just start thinking like,
ah,
I don't know about that.
I j.
A.
N I just feel like that [inaudible] that just sounds like they're sitting on oil
and if they are,
I know we're over there fucking with them.
You know,
decided who their leader was or whatever the fuck we do.
You know what I mean?
You got to do that.
You got to pay attention.
You know,
Singapore is the shit.
I've been there and never been to Malaysia,
Japan.
I got to go there,
right?
I got to do that all.
I gotta do all of that Shit.
That's what I would do.
I'm going to fucking build my whole year and never been to Wimbledon.
I've got to do that.
Oh,
and I got to go to that fucking tt race next year.
Those are the three I'm going to knock off,
right?
F One race,
fucking Wimbledon.
And I'll go to that fucking tt race,
right?
And watch somebody fucking slammed into the side of a seven 11 at about 200
miles an hour or 320 kilometers.
One of the fuck it is.
I don't know.
I don't pretend to know.
Um,
all right,
so I'm off to go to fucking,
um,
grand rapids,
Michigan,
and uh,
I can't wait to do this as such.
Can Be such a fucking fun Gig.
And I completely fell off the fucking wagon.
You know,
I went over this,
I went to this fucking pool party and I had some,
some beers.
And then I've drank every single night.
Not a lot,
but I just been dreaming of.
It's not even getting hammered,
it's just the calories.
But I dialed the drink in way back.
Um,
I tell you,
this is what happens.
We want to go into the fucking writers room.
I've been great in the writer's room,
except today I had a cheeseburger,
but other than that,
I've been in the writer's room for fucking two and a half weeks and I have eaten
salads the entire time.
I have drank waters.
I'm eating fucking fruit.
I'm fucking killing it.
But today my wife came by.
When that guy,
let's go to fucking,
we'll go to shake shack.
Fuck right.
Those burgers are so,
God damn,
this is free advertising.
These burgers are so fucking delicious,
but they didn't fucking need to do like for a five year old,
you know,
every time I see it as I could eat 10 of these things,
they taste so fucking good and you just,
I like three bites.
That thing's gone.
How many steak and shake fucking at steak and shake,
shake shack burgers you think you could eat.
I've eaten so bad in my life.
Like I don't have the tolerance I used to,
but like in my prime,
I bet I could eat five of those.
That's not bad.
Just under five foot 10.
Right.
A fat fuck still.
I got to get on the phone.
I gotta get back on the fucking elliptical.
You know what?
My dog was in town.
I got to see her,
uh,
yesterday and today she's fucking happy.
She looks great.
She looks so fucking great.
You know,
she came over right.
I brought her over to the house.
She met my,
uh,
you know,
I'm a say and my,
she saw Nia again,
was freaking out and all that stuff.
Saw Lola wags her tail and then later looked over at Lola,
you know,
and she was way,
way,
way away by the way.
I made sure she was way the fuck away.
And I had her on a leash the whole time and she looked over and she just went
like fucking growled at her.
I was like,
all right,
there you go.
That's why we don't have you anymore because you are fucking insane fucking
lunatic dog.
I love you to death.
Like I would have to have dog whisperer fucking skills and um,
uh,
you know,
I don't know that,
that it actually gave me closure.
Like I know I made the right fucking decision.
I knew that,
that it was going to be a fucking issue.
Um,
I more thought that she was going to go after she gets so overly protective that
once she bonded with the baby that it was going to be like she couldn't be
lunging at people down the street.
Cause according to my trainer that it would cause her even more fucking anxiety,
um,
that they,
they have like a bay,
you know?
Yeah,
I hear that.
Hey Shit like that.
I have heard stories of like people that like they have a dog,
right?
And then they have like a baby and then the dog like lays underneath the crib.
And the parents are walking to the baby and the dog starts growling.
So then they gotta like get food,
you know,
and throw it to the dog will go get it.
Not realizing that you're rewarding the dog for the behaviors that you don't
want it to do.
It's just too fucking much.
And um,
um,
I yeah,
I am 100% at peace with the decision that we made and I am also so fucking happy
that she has a great home.
She looked fucking amazing and um,
you know,
I got to walk over the last couple of days,
playing what they're and all that type of stuff.
It was really fucking great,
but definitely obviously made the right decision.
You know what I mean?
And I'm not trashing the breed or anything like that.
We just got a dog that was,
I dunno,
this dog got,
it's amazing that this dog has not been put down like fucking nine times.
You know,
this dog is just,
it's like,
it's real.
It's fucking,
they should do a 30 for 30 on this dog.
Like all the fucking shit this dog has been through.
And how it always met people that,
you know,
we're in its corner.
We did it.
We did what we did fucking 2009 to last year.
We did seven years with it at,
uh,
you know,
and now it's,
that's,
you know,
I got a deal,
worked out with my trainer that he's going to keep the dog until she passes and
I'll still be able to visit her and all that.
But that's the last time I'm bringing her buy the house.
It is.
But anytime he comes to town,
I always fun.
Can I go on hikes with her?
And I fucking,
I love the dog to death,
but we definitely made the right decision and uh,
you know,
and I'm still fucking pain cause I still have to pay them.
It's weird.
It's like it's his dog,
but it's still my dog.
So I'm still paying to board the fucking thing.
This fucking dog is gonna is gonna cost me a fortune.
But I absolutely loved that fucking dog to death.
Uh,
I do.
But you know,
uh,
you know,
I knew,
I knew it was going to be a fucking problem.
So,
uh,
and I know all your dog people yet.
They're now he's your energy and is it the Veggie bread?
Fine.
Pin It on me.
I did not have the skills.
And you know what?
My dog's still alive.
My baby's still alive and I'm not on the news.
It's trying to explain what the fuck just happened.
You know what I mean?
Cause I knew something was going to happen.
Someone's going to get bit and then my dog was going to get put down and I was
gonna have to deal with some fucking horrific guilt or something.
So,
uh,
that's it.
That's it.
So anyways,
that is the,
uh,
that is the podcast for a this Thursday.
You guys have yourselves a wonderful weekend.
You can stay there and uh,
thank you to everybody that came out of me.
I was hoping to do one show out there in grand rapids.
We got,
we got fucking two sold out and we've got this other one.
And um,
I am in such a silly,
stupid fucking mood.
Um,
the shit that's coming out of my mouth,
I can't fucking wait to just continue on.
Um,
figuring out what this next hour is going to be.
All right.
That is it.
Um,
oh,
congratulations to fucking Aaron Judge Jesus Christ.
Did you see that fucking display?
I love that they said no one could hit one out of the
baseball stadium and he fucking did it.
It's literally like watching Paul Bunyan.
I'm going to figure out when the fucking Yankees had coming to town.
Hopefully they have an inner league game with the Dodgers so I don't have to
drive all the way down to fucking Anaheim,
which is like a three day trip.
Now you might have people out here.
MMM.
I got to see that guy his rookie season.
I always try to see like when somebody like breaks out like that,
you try to seem that rookie season.
I've been doing that all the way since back like a Allen Iverson.
I saw him his rookie season.
I always tell this story.
I saw him his rookie season before he had the corn rows.
I saw him at the La sports arena.
Biggie smalls was the crowd on that trip when he got murdered.
Uh,
like a few days later and I fucking walked up to him after and he was standing
there.
I remember he had like his,
his security guys were standing there and he looked cooler.
Shitty.
I'd like this purple like long fucking coding.
I like the color of royalty and stuff,
you know,
any,
I'd like these sunglasses on.
And a,
I remember some guy walked by and just went,
baby ba Ba yelled at him.
I mean he just went,
what's up boo?
So just like that and like,
I swear to God,
like what you look up on the schedule,
70 sixers versus the fucking La Clippers.
That was 1997 and it was either like the end of February,
early March.
And that was the trip.
Man.
I keep,
he wasn't alive for like another fucking week.
It was so creepy.
He was only 20 fucking for crazy.
And by the way,
there was just the 10 year anniversary of that or that genius getting fucking
killed.
And they still haven't been able to figure out who the fuck did it.
Unbelievable.
I said,
I can't find who killed Kennedy.
Right?
If you believe in that Shit,
you know what I mean?
How hard they gonna look at for fucking rapper gets shot.
You know what I mean?
They're going to look the other way with a president.
Do you think that was all him?
That single bolt action.
Fucking rifle.
Jesus Christ.
I don't know.
They was a marine.
Who knows?
All right.
I don't know what I'm talking in circles here.
All right,
go fuck yourselves.
Have a great weekend.
I'll talk to you on Monday.
Oh,
watch the,
uh,
the graph Formula One race is going to be a,
where the fuck is it this weekend?
What the Hell's the next one?
Oh,
it's in Britain.
What am I talking about?
Oh,
what's his faces are Lewis Hamilton's a Hong Kong.
Alright,
go fuck yourselves.
I'll see you all.
Listen to the music,
by the way.
I can't end this podcast.
Listen to the music and enjoy a greatest hits Thursday podcast.
Mothers' Day going by in a year that no longer exists.
All right.
No
[inaudible] [inaudible]
you guys see that?
I just saw a commercial,
uh,
for Kentucky Fried Chicken with the parents are all excited because two bratty
kids won't sit still at the dinner table,
but the got I'm this fucking
chicken and they're feeding it to them.
They basically very subtly saying that there's drugs in this chicken that will
make your spastic children chill the fuck out and spastic.
I mean like,
you know,
not,
not the way they mean.
And over there in Great Britain,
you can't say that on the comedies or you can say it in a comedy club over in
Scotland,
but you'll have a rough,
you'll have a rough go of it if you say the kid was spastic over there,
that means like severely a mentally challenged over here.
It just means you're not going to get laid to you at 26
when you were in Grad school looking over a fucking cadaver,
right.
With some other fucking nerve narrowed.
Right.
And you're just sitting there going,
you know the ankle bones connected to the knee bone.
Right.
Has any of this made any sense?
It shouldn't.
It's fucking Sunday night and I am spent and I got a whole bunch of Shit I have
to do tomorrow,
so I got to do it tonight.
All right,
I'm off my game.
you,
you cleanse your liver and like 42 43 days or something like that.
Every drunk I know has told me that every drunk I know that does not have a
medical degree has told me that if you go 42 43 days,
you will cleanse your liver at least to the booze.
You know?
Now if you fucking,
you start doing blow or a,
you know,
eating a bunch of trans fat fucking food or feeding your kids Kentucky Fried
fucking chicken,
Jesus Christ.
What happened to parents that you got drug your kids to keep them under control.
You know,
you know what it is.
Kids don't respect their parents,
they respect them,
but they don't respect like,
oh my God,
this,
this person could wring my neck,
could pick me up by my hair.
Right.
Could grab a paddle and fucking,
you know,
mostly hit my ass,
but also kinda hit my lower back because I'm squirming right.
That doesn't exist anymore.
So now these kids is so fucking out of control.
These people have to go down and Kentucky Fried Chicken.
Okay.
And I,
I,
I use the term chicken very loosely to go down and whatever that is,
that's in that bucket.
Okay.
If it doesn't have a beak,
it doesn't have feet.
If it's fucking,
you know,
chest,
his breasts is sticking out like the cast on fucking,
uh,
what was,
what was that show with the Italians there on New Jersey Shore Jersey shore.
Right.
My world.
That's not a fucking chicken.
You know,
you want the chicken that looked like Mark McGuire in his rookie season.
You don't want to eat the chicken that looks like mark McGwire when he fucking
played for the cardinals.
You know,
do you eat a regular fucking chicken?
First of all,
it's going to look like a pigeon to you because you so used to see in those
roided up ones that they have row that you got down there at you fucking Shaws,
right?
Your Vons,
you,
JC Penney's,
wherever the fuck you buy your goddamn chicken,
you go down,
you go down to any one of the main stream fucking supermarkets.
Okay.
And I swear to God when you get to the chicken section,
okay,
if you've,
if you've slept for the last 30 years,
like that Van Gundy guy under the bridge,
whatever his fucking name is,
Van Morrison,
the hell's his name,
Rip Van Winkle.
Right.
That was one of those people,
one of the vans.
Um,
yeah.
If you slept for the last 30 years and you went down,
okay.
And they showed you what a chicken was,
you'd be like,
ah.
You'd be like,
that ain't no chicken.
Okay?
It's a God damn Turkey.
I know.
Fucking die.
No fucking Turkey when I see one.
Alright.
I no such thing as a mad time.
Fucking chicken can't be done.
No Sir.
Get off my property.
Okay.
I'm,
I'm done with your witchcraft.
Okay.
Yeah.
Said,
get the fuck Outta here.
The fuck off my property.
MMM
honey,
get the gun.
Um,
yeah,
you would think it was a fucking Turkey.
And the thing is,
is now it's a chicken.
And I remember I watched one of those food banks when I was fucking liberal.
Goddamn thinks,
you know,
talking about flying carpets and electric roads and all that bullshit.
Somewhere in there they were talking about,
you know,
the food supply and our poison.
It is poisonous poison in his is.
Um,
so I fucking went down to a farmer's fucking market and um,
I said I wanna,
I wanna,
I wanna all I want,
I want,
I want an all natural fucking chicken.
I can't even talk.
I'm so tired.
One and all natural chicken.
The guy goes,
these are all natural.
And I said,
all natural.
And he goes,
well,
I'm Mike.
Come on,
where is it?
And he had to walk around the corner sitting over there,
lonely.
I swear to God,
looking like a dove look like in somebody killed the fucking dump because right
there,
that one right there is 100% all natural.
Nothing's wrong with it.
And I was like,
okay.
I was like,
what at?
What?
That's what a chicken is supposed to look like.
And he raised his eyebrows and he,
he kind of put his lips together so they were straight line and then he nodded,
you know,
that look that people do like,
like yeah,
I'm in the Matrix.
I realize I'm in the Matrix,
but you know,
I knocked the bitch up so I got to be selling these roided up chickens.
No.
Um,
anyways,
anyway,
what the fuck I'm talking about?
So basically that's what these people are eating over there.
Okay.
They,
uh,
they are drugging up
the kids,
but I can't get mad at him because I actually did that to Murphy and,
uh,
Don l Rawlings.
I've told this story before,
Hey,
I'll tell it against my fucking podcast.
I actually drug I the exact thing that they're doing in that Kentucky Fried
Chicken commercial with it,
trying to get their kids to sit still by just feeding them so full of these
fucking trans fats from these roided up beatless fucking chickens with their
Dolly Parton breasts.
Disses right.
I did that to fucking Don Allan,
Charlie.
I was hung over and we were taking a car service from Chicago xannies up to one
of those whenever the fuck it was
Saint Charles,
it was a three city run and one of them was Saint Charles.
So we're getting in the fucking Limo,
Don L's in rare form.
Charlie's in rare form their fucking Gavin and trash and people in me and
everybody and I just don't want to hear it.
I'm like,
I don't want to listen to these fucking guys running that Goddamn yaps in the
back of this car the whole fucking way up.
I want a nice quiet ride.
This is going to suck.
And I walked outside,
hung over and I walked into the Chicago where you know,
almost got hit by three fat people.
And,
um,
I looked up the street and I saw it,
I saw Popeye's and I was like,
oh,
thank God.
And I fucking walked in there and I got all this fucking Popeye's chicken with
biscuits and all of this shit food.
And I brought it back to the car.
And as the car pulled up,
they came out and I say,
guys,
I got sell some.
I got some food.
And they went,
ah,
that's fucking great.
You know,
they were hungry or whatever.
And they started chowing that fucking Popeye's food.
And I sat back,
nibbling on drum stick,
and I swear to God,
10 minutes later they were asleep.
I'm not lying to you.
They will fucking asleep,
snoring the whole way up.
And I was just sitting there loving life,
the whole fucking write up.
And I,
you know what,
I admitted to them later.
They thought it was funny,
but that's basic what it is.
They call it the Itis,
that's what they call it.
When you eat that shit food and then you have to go to sleep,
they call it the Itis,
I guess.
And by they,
I mean African Americans.
Um,
they call it the fucking ideas and that's what the gut,
and I learned that from Don l because I don't know how that man stayed in shape,
but he had the worst diet.
He's one of those guys who like you stopped for gas and he comes out of the gas
station with like one of those gas station hotdogs
and he would eat it and then he would immediately fall asleep.
And I,
and I would say to Charlie,
look at this guy,
he's sleeping.
And Chad be like,
yeah man,
he got the itis.
And he explained that to me in what,
that little bit of information it went,
my evil white brain and I drug my two African American friends way back in the
year 2005.
Um,
and that's a little chicken story for you.
What time did you like dad?
Everybody.
So that's what the fuck they're saying right there.
That's what Kentucky Fried Chicken is allegedly saying.
I guess I have to say a legit,
so they have lawyers on retainer.
Don't attack my fucking plot podcast as far as I can tell.
I'm asking you right now.
Um,
Kentucky Fried Chicken hiding behind your fucking letters,
KFC.
Is that what the fuck you do?
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah.
If you've got kids who are not stimulated enough that they can't even sit down,
if you haven't read yet to run him around,
you've got to tie your kids out.
Open the door.
You send them out in the fucking yard,
Gad God's side.
Get outside and play.
That's what you do.
Like a Goddamn one of those fucking Irish dogs there was bred to have to,
to herd sheep.
You've got to let that fucking thing run around.
Run around in circles.
Guy,
get out there,
take a ball.
You just fucking throw it out in traffic and let the dog run around.
Dodgy cars that comes in,
it's going to lay down.
Okay?
It's not going to jump all over.
Company sticking its cold nose right in their fucking who has.
That's what you gotta do with your kids.
You've got to send him outside,
right?
But to catch a Predator and all these other fucking shows,
you know,
all these shows on TV where people forget they're kids are in a car with the
windows rolled up.
Their kids are too fucking dumb to roll them down or they're too weak because
they haven't gone outside and climbed a fucking tree and they stay in there and
the,
their,
their brains get cooked like a boxer,
you know,
do you know that dog boxes?
They don't,
they don't do well on this sun.
We'll,
we'll need to do fat kids.
You leave the windows rolled up,
you know,
when they got those weak arms that all he doesn't like.
The most tedious things they ever did was take a wrapper off of a fucking,
uh,
an ice cream sandwich.
Right?
You can't leave them in the car.
My mother left us in the car all the fucking time.
She would go to school,
she was going to school during the day trying to further her education and she
left five fucking kids in the car with the windows rolled up and money for
Burger King.
And she would say to us,
just go into the Burger.
That's the only time you were to leave this car over the left,
over the next three fucking hours when I'm in class.
And she would disappear around the corner after we said,
absolutely mom.
And she walked away.
And uh,
we immediately would get out of the car and start walking up and down the
streets in Boston.
We go into fucking burger king and we,
we'd have something to eat.
Do you know what happened nowadays,
if they just saw five fucking dirty face kids walking up and down,
calm AV Boylston street going into a burger king,
we're going to cast a fucking nanny.
Someone would've filmed it and my mother would have been in,
they would have taken us away,
you know,
but,
but they didn't because there was no cameras back then or videotape ones.
I mean,
there was,
but only the people add them on like the news and a young Steven Spielberg.
So we went in there and we fucking got some food Kleinberg and cars and fucking
yelled at people and Shit,
you know,
hanging on Platt,
parking meters and all that.
Hence we had the fucking forearm strength to roll down the windows and none of
us ever had an issue in the car.
And you know what?
I think that's one to grow on today.
You go people,
I'm not saying KFC is food,
I'm not,
I'm just kidding.
I'm not saying it's bad food.
Every once in a while who's kitten home?
Every once in a,
we don't go anywhere.
He great.
If he could just fucking do heroin the way you can eat Mcdonald's,
just like every once in awhile he just be like,
you know what?
Yeah,
let's just fucking tie off.
Not off for the rest of the fucking day in like the people that work understood
it,
you know?
Hey,
where were you yesterday on any,
I got this black tar heroin came in.
You know,
I hadn't done it like three months away.
Figured fuck it.
Oh,
is that what you did?
How was it?
I wasn't,
you know,
like,
like you went to Aruba,
you said,
oh dude,
it was awesome.
Fucking,
I don't remember shit.
Can you know you get addicted?
Two
[inaudible] [inaudible]
yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
This is built bar and this is the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
July 13th,
2009.
This is my third attempt,
possibly the fourth attempt to,
uh,
try to do this podcast.
But,
uh,
as always,
I got 9,000 things on my mind.
I have to go to the airport and like two fucking hours to fly up to do my shows
in San Francisco,
um,
this evening.
And uh,
I already walked my frigging dog,
so I got that out of the way.
And uh,
I'm actually psyched to be at my apartment this the first time I've been here in
about five weeks and it's nice to be sitting here on my couch with my feet on my
coffee table.
Um,
do I own anything else?
No,
I rent.
So the landlord owns the fucking floor,
but I don't have my feet on it.
All right.
So fuck him
to tell you guys about my place I fucking had,
I came home.
Right.
And you know,
I don't know if you guys have ever left your life for five weeks,
but when you come back,
it's a nightmare.
First of all is like three pounds of mail
and a,
I don't know about you guys,
but every once in awhile I give to one of these,
uh,
you know,
save the wolves or a,
saved this park or save these lepers or whatever the fuck the,
uh,
the causes.
And I swear to God,
don't ever give money through the mail.
Okay.
Give it directly to a homeless guy.
You know,
throw a hamburger to a fucking wolf from your car window,
but for the love of God,
do not get on.
Don't fucking give money through the mail because when you do,
they literally clear out an acre of trees from the rainforest trying to send you
shit to get more money from you.
It's actually annoying.
It's like if you feel like a SAP,
like you just feel like everyone out there who's looking for money,
like your,
your address just lit up like,
oh,
we got a SAP,
we've got a live one here.
He actually gave money.
Holy.
Oh my God,
this guy gives a shit about wolves.
You know,
where the fuck were the wolf's by the way before then,
before they reintroduce them into the parks and they started killing elk and
competing with the bears and more importantly the hunters so the hunters don't
want them there.
Is that,
is that what's going on?
Is that the wolf issue?
You know what exactly is going on?
You're Wolfe's where the fuck are wolves anyways?
Is there any place out there and you know is not a fucking mall at this point?
I don't know.
Huh?
Was that intriguing for your Monday?
Might have a citizen fucking that'll get the conversation going,
Huh?
All right.
This podcast is sucked so far and so I know a podcast sucked if fucking three
minutes into it.
I'm already looking for questions that people have sent me.
All right.
I'm a little out of it.
People.
I went and I went,
I went a little hardcore the other night as always,
which is why I'm shutting it down.
And I'm,
I'm,
I'm just drinking cranberry juice with Lyme now after my shows for awhile.
Okay.
And all you fucking douchebags who've watched the departed will all come up to
me.
They were you on your period?
Did you fucking see that movie that 9 million other fucking people saw,
hey,
when people quote fucking lines from movies,
you know,
like,
like the country didn't see it already.
You know what I mean?
It's like you're already telling an old fucking joke.
Nobody cares.
All right.
Did I say I was in a good mood this week?
I don't sound like it.
Do I?
Um,
girlfriends laughing at me.
All right.
Um,
all right,
let's get to the,
uh,
oh,
wait a minute.
You know,
I,
I didn't finish telling the story now I want a little hard.
The other night,
I actually a,
I ordered that UFC fight and I had a couple of friends come over who will all
remain nameless because I'm a guy's guy and I won't name names.
Huh?
You like that?
Like how I just dubbed myself a guy's guy,
you know,
if Michael Jackson can give himself a fucking nickname,
why can't I give myself one bill?
Burn the guy's guy,
the king of guys guys.
And uh,
you know,
I got a lot of,
I got an email.
This guy was,
I got a couple of emails of people giving me Shit,
uh,
saying I completely dropped the ball when it came to Michael Jackson's death and
I just talked about what a big star he was and I didn't chastise them for,
uh,
stuff that he got acquitted of.
And uh,
and you know,
I disagree with you.
I 100%.
I think the hacky way to go on that one was to talk about how the guy,
you know,
is,
is to be that moron who walks around saying that,
you know,
he's guilty of that shit even though he was never convicted.
Okay.
Now,
I know the guy got a tie.
He's got a ton of fucking money and all of that stuff.
But you know,
I'm not saying he did.
I'm not saying he didn't,
but you know,
that's so,
I don't know.
I just thought that that was a hacky way to go to be,
you know,
considering some fucking congressmen out on Long Island did some rant,
and put it up on youtube and got like a zillion hits.
I mean,
right there,
you know that that's a hacky route to go is a comedian.
If fucking some guy who,
you know,
where's like penny loafers without socks.
You know,
if that guy can come up with a fucking video of the shit,
you know what I mean?
Why don't,
why don't you go watch that guy's video for his insightful,
just goes and fucking kid folker UNOS.
This goes,
you're fucking freak.
You know those people who just go that complete need your,
I mean,
how,
how in an interesting is it to go that fucking route,
you know,
hey,
you know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to state the obvious,
you know,
this guy's weird.
He had 9,000 plastic surgeries.
What the fuck is with this guy and go the exact same route.
People went with that chick with the eight fucking babies.
Did that make any sense whatsoever?
I'm just saying,
you know Jesus Christ.
Well then when I,
when I'm talking about Elvis was fat while I'm at it,
you know.
All right.
Anyways,
I was watching that UFC you guys want shut the other night,
Brock Lesnar probably had the best post fight interview I've ever seen in my
life.
He basically pounded this guy,
was it frank Mir and I don't even know the fucking names.
I'm out of the loop when it comes to that shit.
This guy basically to just,
if you're not into the UFC,
this is how big the guy basically has a tattoo of a sword on his chest and he's
so big.
I think it's like fucking actual size.
You know what I mean?
Like if I got that tattoo would look like a little paring knife on my chest
where his literally he's got the fuck.
It's like a Samurai sword.
It star.
I don't even think it starts.
It starts like above his navel and it goes all the way up to his neck.
And of course he has the pointed the sword at his fucking throat.
Guys,
just a maniac.
You know what I love too was when he lost,
when he won,
the crowd starts booing him and immediately gives everybody the finger.
And when he comes up to the microphone,
everyone's born and when he's gone,
I love it.
And you could clearly see that he didn't love it.
You know Haiti,
Brock,
you didn't love it.
You want to be loved.
Okay.
But it was great.
He wrote,
they,
I think they finally have a good heel and the UFC,
you know what I mean?
You Watch these guys,
these guys are the toughest motherfuckers on the planet.
And for the most part,
when they end the fights,
they always just compliment the other guy.
Say,
I respect the guy,
or whatever.
But this night was,
it was fucking great.
This one guy knocked out this other dude.
The guys just lay in there on the ground.
And then this the fucking dude who knocks him out.
Then for some reason,
leaps up into the air and just lands on them and punches him in the face again.
It was like attempted murder and then he like admits to it at the end of the
fight.
Like,
yeah,
I did that.
I did the second one because,
uh,
you know,
we talked a lot of shit.
It was great.
He was total thunder.
Dolman uh,
unlike a lot of paper views that you'd throw your fucking money down and
afterwards you feel like you got raped.
I definitely feel like I got my money's worth.
So,
uh,
um,
there you go.
If you,
if you want to pick a pay for pay per view,
go with the UFC.
Um,
what the fuck did Brock say?
He said something like,
uh,
he's like,
God,
that guy,
you know,
the guy fighting,
he goes yellow,
horseshoe up his ass last fight.
I pulled it out and I,
you it over his head.
Woo.
And he had like to psycho fucking date rape vibe.
I'm literally waking up my entire fucking complex,
doing a bad impression of fucking Brock Lesnar.
All I all,
whatever was a great thing.
Let's go to the gas bill.
All right,
let me get out of this fucking thing because you know,
half,
you know as I'm doing this podcast,
half of my brain's going,
dude,
you haven't packed yet and um,
I'm not going to pack shit anyway.
So this is one of these overnight gigs.
What I do is I basically wear the shoes.
So I have them,
I wear the shoes that I'm going to wear on stage,
right.
And then I just,
whatever I wear in the planes,
whenever I went on the plane and I just fucking pack my,
my,
my pants and the shirt that I'm going to wear that night.
And then like a fucking toothbrush,
toothpaste,
shave and shit,
I put it into a lunch back little plastic thing and I throw it in and that's
fucking it.
That's it.
And I zip right through the airport,
you know,
security guards looking at me,
what's with this guy?
He doesn't have any luggage.
The fucks with this guy.
I'll tell you what the fuck's with this guy.
He's going to San Francisco.
He's coming right back and he doesn't have any drugs in his ass.
All right.
I'm telling jokes.
Stop fucking looking at me.
All right,
let's go to ask bill.
Um,
here's an interesting question.
Uh,
Bill,
I've been dating the same girl for about two and a half years now.
We've talked about having a threesome,
but I've never met the right girl to do it with.
Oh,
okay.
Here we go.
This is called the beginning of the end of a relationship.
Um,
we're tired of fucking each other and we've admitted it to one another and now
we're going to go outside the relationship,
but we're too codependent to break up with one another.
I'm just fucking with you.
All right.
Here we go.
Uh,
he says,
I'm 28 and my girlfriend is 26.
About two months ago,
I added some,
I added some random cougar to my Facebook who is 42.
Uh,
right now it's getting interesting.
my girlfriend got all pissed about it and we had a minor fight.
Fast forward to this past Thursday and my girlfriend runs into the cougar at a
bar while she's out getting hammered.
Okay,
timeout.
You added some random cougar on Facebook.
There's what?
4 billion people on Facebook and somehow your girlfriend runs into the random
cougar.
Dude,
you added an old fucking broad.
You met in a bar down the street.
Are you on Facebook?
Yeah,
I'm on Facebook.
You know,
add me.
She's probably already rubbed one out.
Huh?
Were there old wrinkled up hand?
She probably already gave you a hand job,
but the local Hooters didn't.
You didn't,
she write and then you fucking load.
Then you feel guilty and you're like,
all right,
well if I include her with my girlfriend,
maybe I can get some of that.
I just sorta cheated stench off of me.
All right,
I'm judging.
I'm sorry.
Let's plow ahead here.
So we goes,
uh,
I'm at home and I get a call from my girl at one in the morning who says,
I met the chick you added on Facebook and we should have a threesome with her.
Good for her.
Jesus Christ.
All right.
At first I was kind of excited,
but then my girlfriend says she wanted to take her back to the apartment to
experiment with just the two of them.
Uh,
this cougars good.
She's good.
She's sweet,
talked to you,
right,
sweet talk to you and now she's sweet talking your girlfriend.
Um,
she's in.
The guy says,
ah.
I freaked out and told her that it would hurt my feelings if she messed around
without me.
Basically.
My question is,
is it cheating for my girlfriend to hook up with another chick if I'm not there?
All right,
dude.
You know what?
You're asking the wrong question.
If I could be so bold here,
the question you should really be asking yourself right now is when you look at
your girlfriend,
you got to say,
is this the future mother of my children?
If it is,
don't have a threesome with her.
Okay.
Because I don't care how much you love her.
The sight of her going down on that old clam is just something that,
yeah,
it's just something that I just psychologically,
I don't know how you're going to be,
that's going to be holding your child something that hopefully 50% looks like
you one day.
You know what I'm saying?
That's just a,
uh,
you know,
seriously do it.
If this is this,
if this is the woman you want to marry and man,
come on man,
some dusty old broad down the street.
You guys are going to fucking do an indecent proposal with that.
You know,
I could see if you a,
there's something about going to another country or a far away place and doing
something like that because you know,
you get to play that,
oh,
we're just different people now.
And then you come back and you act like it never happened.
You just compartmentalize it and you know,
it comes up in an argument,
you know,
fucking 12 years later,
but by then who gives a shit because you're both old and out of shape.
But to go right down this street,
you're basically shitting way you're eating.
Um,
I dunno,
Dude.
I like,
if you're not going to marry this girl,
then you know why not?
I would do it for the story,
but,
uh,
if you really think that this is the girl you're going to marry,
I would,
I would tap out of this one.
I'd wait for a,
I'd wait for some fresher fish.
Jesus Christ.
Bill.
Sorry.
I've been really crude lately on this thing.
Um,
but anyways,
I will ask your question is,
is it cheating for my girlfriend to hook up with another chick if I'm not there?
Um,
uh,
Jesus Christ,
this is just another one where women get away with it.
Right?
I don't know.
Would it be cheating if you went out and blew your best friend?
I think it's just kind of fucking weird.
There's just something about if you have the same sexual parts,
it's like,
it's less cheating.
It's more weird.
Yeah.
It is weird if she's fucking there and then she's just having a full on lesbian
thing where if you're there too,
then it's just sorta like you're adding to like the candy dish.
You know what I mean?
It's another little spice in there.
Hey,
I already got one vagina.
Oh look,
there's another one.
You know what I mean?
And you know,
you get to stack them up.
What you want to do is have the three on one and you just stack them all up.
What I,
I call that the traffic light,
right?
Ah,
Shit.
I think I just coined a phrase there.
I love how I'm acting like I've actually done any of this.
I haven't done any of that.
You know,
actually care about my girlfriend and is as much as I'd want to have a fucking
two on one.
I just,
I couldn't,
I actually mean that she's sitting over there putting lotion on herself.
Like,
are you getting all adorable?
Why?
Why are you looking all nice now that I'm leaving town?
Huh?
What do you got?
Some office boyfriend.
I'm sick of that lavender robe.
My girl has this fucking robe.
This is way too personal,
but I really need to,
but yeah,
he really need to get a new one over the,
dress it up a little differently.
Is that the dog?
Okay.
Fucking codependent.
Pitbull.
Can you believe that shit.
So anyways,
dude,
you know what?
I would be honest,
like this is the deal,
man.
If you're not going to,
if you're not going to stay with this girl,
by all means fucking do it.
By all means do it.
But if you actually love this girl and you're going to marry this girl,
Dee,
do you really want,
I mean,
the next time you guys get tested for whatever fucking reason,
you know you get a worry because you,
you,
you put your Dick in and be Davis.
What are the fucking name was the name of that chick who played?
Alison said Alice,
what the fuck was the name of that?
And Hey,
what's the name of the housekeeper on the Brady Bunch was Alice,
right?
It was Alice.
Some reason it came out of my mouth.
It didn't sound right.
All right.
Um,
oh,
and this is the best part of the email.
The guy goes,
ps,
I tried to use small words in this email because I know how you suck at reading
things off your computer.
Ah,
Shit.
That really made me laugh.
All right.
Even though I didn't live right there.
It did make me laugh because it was the excitement that it was new.
Then I just read it again and it wasn't new to me,
so I gave it a lifeless read,
which goes back to what I was talking about earlier.
When people quote shit from movies that you've already seen and when you meet,
somebody comes up to you and they're like a,
hey,
have you seen the depart and what?
Have you seen the department yet?
Yeah,
yeah,
I saw it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that one part and they were in the bar.
I saw it,
and they just keep plowing through and no matter what you say,
no matter what you do,
they're going to do the whole fucking scene.
Why can't you just say,
Hey,
listen,
you know that movie you've already seen and you don't want to hear me do,
I'm going to do it anyways.
So it'd be in your best interest if you don't want to be involved in this,
to fucking walk away right now,
because I am unstoppable once,
once I fucking get in this mindset,
you know?
All right.
Let's go onto the next question.
Hey Bill,
first off,
a huge fan of the Monday morning podcast.
Thank you.
Uh,
you've always given some great advice to comedians starting out,
but I was wondering what advice you have for someone with a few years of comedy
under their belt.
I'm a young comic and I have been doing standup for a few years and I've been
doing regular work,
coasting,
featuring,
etc.
But I live in a smaller market.
Uh,
that's a good thing actually when you start now I'm,
I'm moving to La in a month and I'm very excited to dive into the big comedy
scene and looking forward to the challenge.
I was wondering,
Bill,
your thoughts on the various comedy stages in town.
You see beavers,
the comedy store versus the laugh,
laugh factory and so on.
What is the vibe from place to place,
which is your favorite since you moved to town?
All right.
This is my whole vibe,
uh,
as far as,
okay,
you're in a small market,
you started in a small market,
that's a great,
that's where,
I mean I'm basically going with my experience because I started in a smaller
market in Boston and uh,
before I moved to New York and then coming here to la.
Um,
so I think starting in a smaller markets better,
it's just easier to get on stage,
less competition.
There's nobody watching you and that type of shit.
And then basically what happens two to three years in,
you start looking around going,
all right,
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here if I'm ever going to get to the next level.
And then you have to make a,
of whether you're going to move to New York or la.
And um,
I dunno,
I was way more of a New York guy,
but you basically,
you should check out both places in whichever one you just feel is drawing you
towards it.
I would go that way.
And as far as what,
um,
the comedy store laugh factory,
you see B?
Um,
I like all of those places and I can tell you this,
if you moving out to la to get into TV and movies and that type of thing,
I would take an Improv class.
It's something that I wish I did and it's something I plan on doing soon.
And,
uh,
it's weird.
It's kind of looked down upon by comedians.
Like when they,
when they look at Improv shows,
they,
you know,
somebody throw out an emotion,
we always consider it like fucking hacky,
whatever.
But,
um,
I dunno,
I,
I think there's a reason why when you watch the office and you watch Saturday
night live and you watch all these shows and so many people are coming from,
uh,
you know,
second city and UCB.
I mean,
I actually went to the Groundlings show,
this guy's buddy of mine now,
she was doing a show down there and I went and I saw it and it was fucking
great.
And when I noticed when I was watching,
it was literally everything that they were doing.
If you tried to do it in stand up,
you would,
you just get raked over the coals by the comedians.
They had props,
they were singing songs.
Uh,
what else?
What else can you not do as a comedian,
um,
without getting beaten with a fucking mic stand?
Um,
you know,
they were up there with other people,
they would dress it up just fucking all this type of shit.
But it was fucking hilarious.
And I remember when I went down that night,
I was watching the show at the Groundlings and it was hilarious.
And then I went to the comedy store,
but it was,
and it was also hilarious,
but I kind of understood why like when you watch an Improv show,
especially if they're doing like sketches,
it's like watching a live TV show.
So you don't really have to think,
there's no thought like,
oh,
can I see this person on TV?
You feel in a way like you're watching a TV show.
Whereas if you watch a comedian,
you know,
what's your more hearing is like a immunologist in Sony,
like spewing out their thoughts,
which is also fucking hilarious.
But I can see why they always approach comedians now to host reality shows or to
uh,
I dunno,
whatever,
all the other shit that they fucking have us go out for.
And I think that we can act because they can't really see us doing it.
So anyways,
um,
you know,
I guess what I'm trying to say is come out here and do standup but don't be,
I would definitely take acting classes,
take those improv classes because it's only going to help you in the long run in
uh,
you know those improv classes.
I think it's kind of like open mics.
You need to go to an open mic cause you need a safe place where you can just
bomb and soc and learn to get good.
Um,
and I feel that you should do the same thing with acting.
You should go to acting class and just fucking bomb and just do a bunch of shit
that you never do if he just went on,
you know,
if you're booked a guest star on a show or if you booked a part in a movie
because you'd be like,
Oh fuck,
I don't know if this is going to fly.
And that's not really the place to see if something's going to bomb is when you,
you,
you book a big Gig and people still don't know who the fuck you are and you make
some big fucking choice.
So,
um,
I dunno,
I like all the clubs out here as far as the standup clubs,
but um,
I would definitely,
if I was you,
that that would be the biggest thing I can tell you is definitely do shit like
that.
So,
uh,
it'll help you with your auditions.
It's something I wish I did back in the day.
And uh,
I don't believe in that everything happens for a fucking reason.
I believe.
No,
I made a mistake and that is one of the mistakes I made in my career is I did
not focus on that shit.
All right.
That was a little sad.
Okay,
let's move on here.
Um,
oh,
here's one that's for your little self checkouts story.
Um,
if you're new to my podcast,
I am 100% against those self checkouts in a grocery stores.
I am not 100% against automation.
I have no automated machines.
I have no problem with the ones that the bank where I have 24 hour access to my
money and just for the simple fact is it takes me two seconds to get my money.
I stick a card in,
I punch in my password,
I say withdrawal.
They say how much I say this much and I have my money as opposed to self
checkout where I have to become a fucking cashier in a bag boy and I have to
scan a week's worth of fucking groceries.
And if something doesn't have the right bar code,
I have to do what?
Get a price check.
I don't know.
Fucking won.
And that's after I stand behind a plumber who's doing the same fucking thing.
And considering it isn't any quicker,
where an ATM at a bank is quicker,
it makes an or automated things at the,
at the airport has made checking in for a flight quicker.
So I want you fucking nerds out there who keep thinking that I'm just against
tech advancements in technology.
I'm not,
I am.
I am against the ones that is not,
they're not an advancement.
It's only an advancement for the fucking big goddamn store.
All they've done is just,
you know,
enabled me to do somebody else's job for fucking free.
And it takes the exact same amount of time,
if not fucking more.
Okay.
If you could come up away for me to scan my fucking groceries in,
it actually was quicker and they magically were bagged.
I wouldn't be doing this shit.
So anyways,
here we go.
This guy says,
so it's 11:00 PM and my fiance is dying for some ice cream.
Everything's closed out there by the time.
Uh,
we get outside the bars and a couple of major,
um,
only a couple of major supermarket chains were open.
So we hit our local Kroger supermarket,
which is open 24 hours.
We grab a pint of ice cream and walked to the register thinking there should be
quick boy,
oh boy were we wrong?
We couldn't believe what we were seeing.
This store had maybe 15 lanes and not one was open.
All we had were four of the do it lanes open and one person overseeing those.
Um,
this would be fine if the four people who are using these registers didn't all
have $150 worth of groceries in their cart.
Plus they were four or five people waiting in front of us as well.
I don't know if you've noticed,
but this is what p uh,
but I don't know if you've noticed this,
notice this,
but when people scan their own item,
it takes approximately twice as long than if an employee is doing it.
Thank you.
That's what the fuck I was saying.
Plus one of the poor people's scanning their groceries was an elderly,
elderly man and one of those drivable carts.
This man could barely move yet he was forced to scan his own shit.
And then when he,
uh,
had to pay,
he couldn't really reach the slot where you put your cash in or slide your
credit card and you could tell he had a very hard time reading the screen from
that far away.
So we finally make our way out of self checkout.
We scan our one item and of course the computer doesn't register that we placed
the ice cream on the bagging area and keeps telling us to remove the last item
and rescan it.
And after that comes up a few times,
I tell,
uh,
it tells us that the employee has been notified and to please wait.
So we look at that one employee sitting there whose only job is to watch a bunch
of suckers do her job and for her,
uh,
and what is she doing playing with their fucking iPhone.
We get our,
we get our attention,
pay and get the fuck out of there.
And to top it all off,
since it's July,
by the time my fiance opened up or Ben and Jerry's was,
she had to wait a half hour for it was all watery,
you know,
just how she likes it.
Uh,
anyways.
Um,
yeah,
see,
I mean,
I dunno,
I've talked about this shit till I'm blue in my face.
I don't understand people who think that big time corporations come up with new
technologies to try and help the customer save money.
Um,
if you want to know how our corporations mentality works,
I can recommend a good,
um,
documentary I saw literally called the corporation and it's a great one because
it isn't like this Michael Moore totally slamming,
you know,
everybody in corporations are evil.
It actually just showed how people incorporations are kind of regular people,
but just the,
uh,
business model in the momentum and the direction that it goes in and how they
always have to show a fucking profit no matter what leads to them doing
literally psychotic shit.
Um,
anyways,
um,
oh,
here's another thing he says.
Get.
Um,
also,
did you see the alleged swimming pool racism thing going on in Philly?
Looks like the wrong person watched your last HBO special.
Yeah,
I got a lot of emails about that.
Um,
I guess that happened the whole get out of the pool thing.
You know,
I think what I was trying to say in that bit was kind of lost.
What I was saying was that white people are evil,
has been documented.
You know,
they started with major subjects like slavery and uh,
they just kept making the movie over and over again.
They had to come up with new subjects to the point it got all the way down to
swimming,
which to me was kind of fucking nitpicking.
But I actually saw somebody sent me a clip of that,
that story on,
uh,
on the Internet.
And it was a classic news story where they just show one side of the new story.
All they showed where the people complaining they didn't show the other side.
And then everyone just has those other people convicted.
Now,
I'm not saying that they,
they fucking didn't do something wrong,
but you got to hear the other side first.
You know,
you got to see what the deal was.
Were they decent kids and they went there and they really got judged or was it a
group of fucking asshole kids?
And then they got booted out and then they just played the race card.
You don't know until you've seen it,
but I can,
I can tell you this.
I don't think it's a smart thing in general to,
uh,
you know,
city kids versus suburban kids.
It's it,
that's never a good thing.
When you grow up in the city,
no matter what color you are,
you age in dog years,
you know,
when I was out in the suburbs playing with the fucking stick in a mud puddle,
the white version of me on the inner city was learning how to fucking,
I dunno,
take ecstasy.
You know,
I mean,
this straight across the board,
Paris Hilton probably went to her first orgy when she was like 11.
You know what I mean?
I dunno,
Ain't no,
and I don't get mushy.
And she's like the king of all whores and I don't give a shit how you take her
out of the city and sticker in a nice fucking park.
She still a psycho whore.
Right.
So just being devil's advocate here,
you know,
that being said,
you really shouldn't have a problem with anybody getting in a fucking pool
unless they're trying to drown your child.
Um,
I hope that made sense.
I hope that didn't come off like an in a Fox News Way.
I didn't mean it that way.
Okay.
But I do fucking exist.
I Dunno.
In my own fucking reality sometimes in my shit doesn't come across the right
way.
So whatever.
Anyways,
you guys can ask me questions.
What I meant by that.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
dating services,
Bill,
what is your opinion on dating sites?
I personally think it's a bunch of shit.
They advertised about how much,
uh,
they match people perfectly and show these happy couples who supposedly have
everything in common.
Um,
what if you don't want to be in this?
What if you don't want to be the same?
What if you want to be happy with someone who is dramatically different.
Those things are for people who have given up all those dating services or
people who have completely given up in life to the point that they have no human
contact.
So they have to sit in front of their computer by themselves to try and get
some,
wow,
that's a little harsh.
Um,
what do I think about them?
it depends on when I see him.
Sometimes I see the commercial and I think they're funny when I'm going through
a rough period in my relationship,
I'm jealous of the people I see on TV because they seem so happy and they're
playing that little zippy piano tune in the background,
you know,
that e harmony and that girl goes,
yeah,
wow,
this good day.
Yeah.
Now the last did love and there's like two people in argyle sweaters crawling
all over each other.
Yeah.
Like it gets fucking annoying.
I'm so,
you know,
I actually did,
I went to a a,
I went to a dating site and I,
I'm actually going to check this fucking thing out here and um,
it,
it goes from creepy.
I Dunno.
The window here seems creepy and nerdy and then there's just one guy on here.
You can tell he's just trying to pull some ass off for this.
All right,
here.
One guy starts with my darling.
I wish to be near you.
All right.
This guy's a psycho and he's got the classic sitting there with his fucking hand
underneath his chin.
I simply wish to be happy together with favorite.dot dot.
I hope that I meet you here and we can be happy and to be one family.
I wait for your letter and then we can learn more each other.
Okay.
This is definitely a second language.
This fucking Pussy Hound.
He's banged everything in his country and now he's coming over here with his
broken English going into a dating site.
I respect that guy.
All right.
Here's another one.
Seeing if Mr right exists.
All right.
First of all,
this girls smile.
Is she smiling like Erik Estrada?
You know,
when you know exactly how many teeth or person has in their mouth,
he shouldn't see somebody molars when they smile.
Anybody else?
Anybody else with that?
You should see basically teeth six to 11,
right?
Six seven eight nine 10 11.
Yeah.
That's canine to canine.
For those of you who've never been to a dental office.
Um,
anyways,
this lady says,
uh,
I'm a fun,
outgoing girl who likes to try new things.
I'm loyal,
trustworthy,
friendly and caring.
I like to go out and meet new people.
I like to hang out at the beach and travel to places that I've never been to
really,
really?
Yeah mean these,
these,
these descriptions is,
are ridiculous.
I like all of those things,
but I'm also prone to fucking road rage.
I accidentally punched my dog in the face the other day.
Did I tell you that?
This is actually true.
I was rolling around with Cleo right up fucking wrestling with her,
right?
Having a great time.
And she's,
she has a tongue,
like a fucking paintbrush.
She licks you twice and you have to take a shower,
you know,
so she gets all excited and she wants to start licking my face.
So I kind of stuck my,
my neck out to keep my head away from her and she brought her fucking rock hard
head up and hit me right in the throat.
I mean,
almost killed.
One was crushed my voicebox right.
I was,
and I was like,
Jesus,
crisis dog.
I'll say,
my God,
this do you believe are hardest fucking dogs head is.
She goes,
oh yeah.
She goes like,
nothing affects.
So you could literally punched her right in the face and it wouldn't even bug
her.
And I was like,
Oh yeah.
And I was trying be funny and I just sort of threw a jab and I tried to pull the
punch,
but she moved her face right into it.
I punched her right in the face just like this,
this hard.
You hear that just like that.
And she didn't even flinch,
cheat,
even shake it off.
She just continued licking my fist and I felt horrible.
Yeah.
I'm telling my story and I punched the dog in the face.
That was brutal,
right?
It was an accident.
I said it was horrible.
All right,
let's read a couple more of these geeky Filipino girl looking for a sweet guy
who spend time with Si there.
There's,
that's,
if I was going to go on one of these sites,
I would more gravitate towards someone who actually kind of had a sense of humor
about themselves as opposed to someone who writes on this journey called life.
I swear to God,
somebody wrote that.
I enjoy traveling and exploring new places,
so why not look online for someone to be able to share journeys together with,
whether it's to a local museum or to exotic locales in distant countries?
Question Mark.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
He had every,
he had every hacky thing in there.
You know,
life being a journey,
going to a museum.
He had everything but talking about watching sunsets.
You know what?
Fuck that guy.
Um,
oh,
here's one guy,
the guy with little five o'clock shadow.
It's nice out.
We should do something.
Hi,
I'm Daniel.
I like being outdoors,
traveling,
photography and learning new things.
A mellow and can be somewhat shy when meeting new people,
but I open up pretty quickly with the right person.
In other words,
he's going to be a sweetheart until you get them alone in your fucking
apartment.
He's going to tear your clothes off.
Who is this person?
Um,
all right.
And search of for a hand to hold me psycho.
Everything happens for a reason.
Good and bad.
Okay.
That guy's depressed.
I love and enjoy my life in La.
I am looking for a partner who can be my best friend and share things together.
She looks creepy.
Uh Oh.
Here's one girl looking for a guy who's going to show her a good time and
appreciate her.
All right,
her dad didn't stick around.
She'll blow you easily within the first three hours.
I'm looking for a genuine guy.
The best way to describe myself is,
is easy going individual on genuine,
down to earth.
You know these fucking people,
they're all full of themselves.
Here's a guy just looking for fucking ass right here.
We stand here in a Tuxedo.
Work hard,
play hard.
I am new to the South Bay and I have only lived in California for nine months.
I know when you're looking for some ass to tag.
Here's the last one.
Beauty isn't only physical,
but in
Inter beauty plays a major factor.
All right.
That means she's a fat chick.
That's me.
But it's fucking true.
She is fat.
Um,
all right,
let's plow ahead.
Um,
what,
what is,
what's my feeling on those?
I Dunno.
I Dunno what I'm feeling is,
uh,
I would feel like a loser if I went on one of those.
Um,
but I think the older you get,
the less you would feel like a loser unless you're just doing it just to get
more pussy than I kind of respect it,
you know?
All right.
There you go.
Was that ignorant enough for you?
Is that the usual level of ignorance that you expect on this podcast?
All right.
Sports Bill,
you talk a lot about sports and your podcasts and I enjoy your passion.
Um,
but for life,
I'm,
I'm from Australia,
but for the life of me,
I,
for the life of me,
I can't understand the appeal of American football.
When I was living in Seattle,
I went to a few Seahawks game and I found the game tedious as it stops starting
nature totally put me off.
Do you think you need to grow up with the sport to enjoy it?
Um,
I mean I enjoy watching hockey and the occasional baseball game by just can't
get into American football.
I usually watch Australian rules football during the winter.
The best way to describe it as a contact version of soccer and basketball.
Um,
yeah,
I think you need to grow up with it.
I gotta be honest with you.
I went through a good five year period where I found NFL football mind numbingly
boring for the same reasons you're saying.
I just,
it just stop,
start,
stop,
start.
Um,
I don't know.
I think,
I dunno.
I have add,
man.
I like hockey.
It just keeps going.
It just,
it doesn't stop.
There's not 58 fucking timeouts like basketball where the last four minutes
takes two hours to play.
Um,
yeah,
I can see that.
I can see,
um,
cause like I,
I wasn't really into soccer.
I watched American soccer,
which is horrible because the crowd doesn't really give a shit or are the way
they broadcast it is just,
it's just not presented well.
But when I watched like the premier league or something like that,
you know,
overseas stuff and everybody's singing songs and got their scarves on and going
fucking bananas,
I actually can get into it,
you know?
And I liked that when there's 90 minutes it takes about 90 minutes other than
the,
the extra time for whatever penalties.
But the one thing I don't like about soccer is anytime anybody gets barely
nicked in the Shin,
they fucking collapsed down to the ground.
Like they got hit by a truck.
It's like,
it's like the whole field is a bunch of pile Gus salts.
That's what I can't stand about soccer.
And it's like,
dude,
you have on Shin Guards.
So I want to know for you a anybody from around the world when you play soccer,
does it really hurt that much?
I'm not talking if somebody has got spikes on and they step on your ankle,
I understand that that's going to hurt.
But when they kick you in the Shin and you're wearing shin guards,
do you really have to roll around on the floor like that?
Huh?
Like the fucking pussy that you are?
Um,
oh,
somebody sent me a funny email going,
hey bill,
great.
Uh,
point about nobody good looking being in England ever coming from England and
they said signed,
uh,
whatever that soccer player's name is.
Who came over here that no one gives a shit about.
And uh,
oh,
one who,
who's,
who's that Horry looking girl that went out with that guy?
I got the fucking prostitute.
Hugh grant.
What the hell was that name?
Was that Linda Lavin?
I never can remember the names.
Lisa Lohan.
Lisa Kudrow loose.
Lisa Hurley.
Kelly Hurley.
Liz Hurley.
There we go.
Thank you.
From the other room.
Look,
India,
she's actually helped me out this week.
Is this from a dating site.
Oh,
qualifications.
All right,
this,
this basically this guy looks like a 58 year old pediatrician,
um,
you know,
bald,
white dude with a coffee stain teeth,
a big psychotic fucking grin.
And he's looking for a smart,
sexy spiritual goddess,
desired for awesome relationship with extraordinary man.
Uh,
how insecure as this guy isn't.
One of these guys would probably fucking has to sail boat around the world to
prove something to himself.
You know,
I did,
man,
I found out about myself when I was out there jerking off in the middle of the
Indian Ocean.
Um,
anyways,
so uh,
one gentleman,
his quest to find his goddess.
Are you capital letters?
A woman who has most of the extensive goddess qualifications,
at least he's being realistic.
As long as you got most,
I'm,
here we go.
Table of context.
Oh my God.
Hi,
I'm mark.
Thanks for visiting my site.
I'm looking for a true goddess for a life long intimate relationship.
Dude,
you have 58,
you're looking for a 15 year relationship and that's if that's,
if he eat vegetables and awesome marriage.
She is highly intelligent.
Very sexy and deeply spiritual.
All those highly,
very in deeply are all capitalized.
Please accept my apology for the length of this message.
There's really no way to condense it into a nutshell.
Well,
I'm going to condense it right now.
Table of contents.
He has a table of contents.
Number one.
Chapter one is it says my global vision.
I fucking love this guy too.
What do I mean by goddess?
Three?
Extensive qualifications for goddess.
I seek note 100% is not required.
3.1.
Spirituality,
3.2.
Body 3.3.
Mine.
Social work,
vision,
sexuality for is about me.
Uh,
five geography,
six surrender versus control.
Wow.
Jesus Christ.
What do you guys want to hear is global vision.
This is really long.
So I'll tell you what I'll give you.
I'll give you the,
uh,
I'll give you the website and you guys can read this and if you want to talk
about it next week,
I will cause this is only like 10 pages a www.findingmygoddess.com.
Um,
no spaces finding my goddess.com.
Jesus Christ.
He's fucking putting it out there.
All right.
I gotta,
I gotta I gotta fucking wrap this podcast up.
Um,
what am I going to do here?
I'm going to be at the punchline in San Francisco tonight for two shows.
This is,
this marks my triumphant return to the stand up stage after,
uh,
I have not headlined in Caroline's was none.
No,
I did the Improv out here in two months.
So I did a quick set the other night at the comedy store and I got to tell you,
I,
I immediately,
the second I went in there,
I felt like I was at home.
You know,
I can't explain it.
I hope you guys have that when you walk into your job.
Cause it's a great fucking feeling,
you know,
rather than,
than go in there and just being like,
oh my God,
when is this going to be over?
Not saying that never happens,
but,
um,
yeah,
I'm psyched to,
to,
uh,
to be back out there.
And I'm,
like I said,
I'm going to be doing,
uh,
a standup special at the end of this year.
So I'm going to try to,
I'm going to try to do some clean living here.
Plenty of water,
eight hours sleep.
No.
Who was no booze,
no nothing.
Watching telly,
nothing.
Um,
so see I just did a quote from a movie anyways.
let's do a couple of overrated,
underrated and then that's going to be,
that's going to be it.
I'm also going to be at the comedy works in Denver this week.
Uh,
I mean this month,
July 23rd,
24th and 25th and young Jo de Rosa.
We'll be doing a number of my fall dates as I get geared up from my,
uh,
my,
my next special,
which I hope I will make special.
You know,
I hope it's not just going to be yet another special yet another guy with his
wacky take on life.
You know,
here's some for you guys.
Like I really can't stand like the weird level of respect and disrespect that
standup comedy gets.
Like when you meet people and you tell them you're a comedian,
they always say,
oh my God,
I have so much admiration.
I would never have the nerve to do that.
Right.
They always say that shit.
Okay.
But then whenever they write about stand up or whenever they do what they,
they're doing a caricature of a standup.
It's always the most horrific,
obnoxious like tables.
What's up with that?
You know,
they still like,
I think stand up comedy is still suffering from the and the tail end of the
eighties.
Boom.
As far as people's idea of what it is.
Because for the life of me,
every time I read a fucking article about standup comedy,
they always say this like recently I saw this article on Glenn Beck.
He's one of these,
uh,
well I don't know what you would call them.
They are like a celebrity journalists,
I don't know.
Personality.
They like celebrity personalities.
They're kind of like,
who's that girl?
Waba Waba Waba go by.
And God blessed though that if like downtown Judy Brown did the fucking news
that that's what these guys are like,
that they're sort sorta,
I don't know.
I can't explain what the fuck they are.
You know,
they should be opening Hooters around the country.
Right.
So this guy,
basically Glenn Beck is going out and he's doing stand up.
So somebody asks him going,
Oh,
you're going to go out and go do stand up?
And he goes,
well he,
I mean,
I'm not going to be on stage going,
what's the deal with airline food at a local Yuk?
Yuks I'm actually going to be going out telling stories that at the end we'll
have a funny punchline,
you know,
something unique.
Something do something different.
Just like everything I did I do or whatever.
It's like,
Oh yeah,
I wish bill Cosby,
you know,
at some point in his career decided to tell a fucking story.
That was funny in the end,
you know,
uh,
she's fucking drives me nuts and what that fucking my whole career,
nobody has done jokes.
I've been doing it 17 years.
Nobody has done jokes about airline food.
Nobody yet,
it is still defined by all those fucking guys dressed in their Miami vice sport
coats with the fucking sleeves pulled up that did jokes after joke after joke
about going to the dentist and about airline fucking food and safety.
I mean,
you're going on 20 years ago.
if you want to make fun of stand up,
I understand because there's nothing worse than a bad comedian,
but at least updated,
you know,
say some shit like,
I'm not going to be up there,
you know,
doing tired material about Monica Lewinsky or even George Bushes and his fucking
old at this point,
you know.
But Geez,
enough with the fucking airline from,
nobody's doing,
I saw one time they were doing a story on some alternative comics and I don't
know if you've noticed this,
but whenever they do a story about alternative comedy,
they somehow have to trash mainstream comics.
I don't know why,
but they do.
And they're like,
yeah,
this is alternative comedy.
This isn't some guy in a mainstream club working out five minutes of material
about airline,
about,
you know,
flying on an airline for his next Letterman audition.
Someone actually wrote that.
All right.
People don't talk about airline.
Okay,
we don't,
okay.
We still compare men to women,
but you know,
I'm just saying if you're going to fucking trash us,
you just have the decency to,
to,
to do a little bit of research,
you know.
Ah,
I would love to go see Glen Beck and just start fucking heckling him,
you know.
Anyways.
Alright.
Uh,
overrated,
underrated.
Hey,
a bill.
Um,
here's my overrated for this week.
Rachel Ray,
she started out with their show on the food network called 30 minute meals,
which was fine.
She made tasty family meals that were easy and fast and she sort of put forth a
homey vibe.
Then she got another show and then another.
Now she has four shows on the food network,
half of which are just her eating food and different countries saying Jamo and
why the fuck does she have her own talk show?
She is far from Oprah or even Tyra.
I'm sick of her acting like she's normal that she can relate to everyone.
Fuck you Rachel.
I don't think I have to add to that.
You really can't stand her.
Um,
I dunno if I was you,
I'd stop watching the fucking food network.
A watch.
Ah,
Mario Batali,
you know,
if you can get over his orange clogs.
He really cooks a lot of great food.
I'm overrated.
The fucking Jonas brothers.
How the hell are these no talent?
Douchebags famous while they're adorable,
they can play their own instruments and they are squeaky clean with their
virginal genitalia.
Anyways,
he goes,
I help all three of these faggots get car bombed.
Jesus Christ,
Dude.
Um,
next,
uh,
overrated.
Those men are evil movies on lifetime.
I don't have to name them.
And other words,
you've never watched them,
but you know,
they suck.
I'm agreeing with you.
Hear those shitty movies make me want to fire bomb the set of the view like it's
Dresden.
What does that have to do with anything?
It says the peanut gallery where I'll tell you what it has to do a,
the view was a bunch of broads running the yaps who don't know what the fuck
they're talking about.
That's what he's trying to say there.
Because what does that have to do with lifetime?
Because see what I did right there.
That is an old stand up a skill that a lot of times the crowd can hear what the
person heckling you said.
So what you do as you repeat what they say,
what does that have to do with lifetime?
Cause they always have those fucking movies about guys throwing women into
fireplaces
cause the views a bunch of women sitting around a spewing out there.
Their thoughts.
Yeah,
their opinions.
because it's a bunch of women.
It's really,
there's,
there's not a lot of layers to this.
Nia is basically,
he doesn't like lifetime.
Huh?
Don't use your real name.
Well I told you I didn't want to put you in my top fucking 10
all right,
well I can always edit this out.
No,
I can't.
I don't know how to use,
I don't know how to use garageband.
Look,
if you don't want to be part of the podcast,
don't fucking chime in.
Don't chime in.
All right.
Okay.
See you later.
All right.
Underrated.
Ak 47 [inaudible]
to most people.
I'm going to wrap it up.
My second AK 47 is to most people,
these are shitty guns,
the terrorist carry around and movies,
but they are,
this guy's a fucking maniac.
He wants to kill the Jonas brothers and he's into AK 47.
[inaudible].
All right,
we're going to end on that.
All right.
Um,
hope you guys enjoy the podcast.
Please come out and support my shows and a,
I'm going to be gearing up for my next special,
so yeah,
please come out and see me.
I added some dates and I'm going to be adding some more dates,
especially come September,
October,
November when I really,
uh,
start buckling down so I don't suck.
All right.
You guys all have a good,
uh,
a good week and I'll talk to you next week.
All right,
thanks.
Bye.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].